[Musik]
dann gelangen hollywood wasser vorjahr
ernsthaft hallo herzlich willkommen zu
15 minuten
dies lade würde ich da das heißt ihr
müsst mit mehr vorlieb nehmen
das heißt ich werde euch etwas ganz ganz
tolles ganz einfach kochen und zwar
mache ich ein kännchen snuko und zwar
ein hähnchen kerbel so richtig ja also
noch ein bisschen mehr als drin ja und
was ist so so heißt auch italienisch
eigentlich so sehr das ist etwas
dickflüssiger als tomatensoße und etwas
flüssiger als pest weil sonst so ein
zwischending und da machen wir etwas
richtig ganz ganz tolles und wir fangen
jetzt auch gleich an uns war das erste
was ich machen werde ist die zytologie
zu sagen richtig dort gut aufgepasst
passt auch sein mag dass thomas ernst
die zutaten so jetzt haben wir zwei
kleine karten münchen wie auch immer
dann haben wir ein bisschen immer zwei
zwiebeln
ich würde das rote zwiebel nehmen dann
habe ich einmal eine knoblauch zwei
esslöffel olivenöl 75 gramm geröstet und
gesalzen erdnüsse dann haben wir zwei
mal 200 gramm hühnchenbrust dann haben
wir hier 500 gramm für alle 400 gramm
kokosnussmilch 400 gramm kokosmilch
bitte ungesüßter dann haben wir etwas
kerbel salz und pfeffer als allererstes
nicht dass die hähnchenbrust und die
hähnchenbrust ich tue die nach dem
verpacken eigentlich immer zuerst mal
kurz abwaschen und dass diejenigen brust
tue ich jetzt in kleine stücke schneiden
und zwar ihr könnt den würfeln in
scheiben schneiden wie ihr möchtet ihr
seht ich werde mit meiner
schneidetechnik auch immer besser warum
warum werde ich besser mit meiner
steigen täglich weil wir schon mal eine
kochsendung gesehen ist ja erstes und
zweites ich habe jetzt in der mast
messer
also kommen müsse das messer kommt aus
nein aus
dumme antwort es kommt aus japan
wieder was gelernt wieder was gelernt so
ist ja ganz ganz wichtig wir machen hier
mit nicht kochen auf auf geringem
bildungsniveau dass auch der siag
versteht was ich hier mache ich habe ich
rechts ragt hier gut sie haben das ist
alles bisschen so aus wie ich schneide
aber es passt ich schneide es jetzt
einfach zu wissen weder würfel noch
scheiben ein zwischending ganz logisch
natürlich umso kleiner das fleisch umso
schneller ist es durch war hier ist ganz
ganz wichtig es sollte nicht durch sein
sonst wird's ziemlich trocken dann immer
das gleiche wir haben unser olivenöl in
die panerai so ganz langsam anfangen zu
erhitzen warum langsam die amag wichtig
damit sich die fahne nicht so ganz
langsam auf jeden fall das war die
falsche platte müssen die richtige
platte nehmen oder tun es nur ganz kurz
anbraten projekt muss wieder auf die
seite und lagen die panne war mit typ
schon mal das nudelwasser aufsetzen und
zwar nehme ich dafür ganz einfach wasser
nudelwasser
minute was aus japan kommt wieder
weil die nudeln genau richtig so setzt
man das nun besser auf wir denken nur
die wasseraufnahme das ganze ganz
einfach ist jetzt stellen sich die frage
tut mir jetzt zuerst salzen oder erst
nachhinein salzen
der markt tut mir zuerst salz ins wasser
oder ersten und dann zu erfassen ja und
warum sie am 8
eine lösung ist ja gleich mal falsch
oder falsch warum trägst du fragen der
nudel ist immer da
salzen tut wer das gegenteil behauptet
der lügt ich zuerst versalzen
wahrscheinlich shopping weißt du mir das
fleisch indes 02 10 wasser nein nicht
hab mir gedacht dass ich so doof bin
nicht ich tue ist nämlich die panne war
jetzt besser nicht genommen warum bauen
ist ein messer nicht genommen wenn ein
löffel lag richtig da machen wir weiter
löffel können ein bisschen stärker hoch
heizen und es ist was falsch ist was
nudelwasser in der zwischenzeit nur
dieses brett weg warum tom beck weil sie
das hähnchen war aufgeschnitten richtig
warum macht man das nicht wegen irrtums
können fleisch und gemüse auf einem
brett man richtig haben uns bleibt
sauber gemacht
frisches brett und hier tun wir in der
zwischenzeit so lange das herrchen
anbrät warum rede sehe nicht ein warum
richtig war die falsche platte jetzt
nehmen wir jetzt zwischenzeit
ach gott geht es schnell jetzt muss
schnell wieder runter
so nur kurz anbraten es mit uns bei der
zwischenzeit immer die roten zwiebel und
ich bin rote zwiebel vom geschmack her
besser deswegen nehme ich auch mal
schneiden ist einmal hier durch und
jetzt mache ich und so machen wir das so
so macht man das so
so kann es schnell würfeln ich habe es
gewürfelt jetzt muss es schnell gehen
nochmal die zwiebeln zweite ziel geht es
auch einfacher eigentlich ja das geht
wesentlich ein paar aber ich mich
eigentlich verletzten
ich glaube es nicht immer so ein gerät
zu helfen
ja geht auch aber ich bin mein ich
brauche keine geräte warum warum brauche
ich keine geräte genau ich bin selbst
das gerät soll jetzt die zwiebeln
gewürfelt oder gestiftet je nachdem wie
man sieht ist ansichtssache
so was machen als nächstes tun
die chaoten sie nicht schön die habe ich
im kühlschrank gefunden
das länger aber das ist den karotten
egal
so jetzt mal das gleiche wie den
karotten immer aufpassen nie so und
einen drauf hatten wir sonst in die
finger weg jetzt hat die karotten
die würfel
sieht nicht schön aus aber das ist ihr
wichtig hauptsache es schmeckt
jetzt sieht man immer den immer nehmen
ein stück weil er immer ist ziemlich
mächtig jetzt mal fehlen aber erst
zugleich zum schielen also schleichen
direkt ohne zu sehen
es ist immer eigentlich egal wir haben
auch eine knoblauchzehe und schädel mir
auch was ist der unterschied ob man eine
knoblauchzehe schneidet hakt oder presst
traum meister dass bei einem wird's
bitter weil wir jemals peter weiss essen
oder schneiden mobil später leistete
nein und zwar ich kann es euch ganz
genau sagen ist der knoblauch egal
das ist ein mythos dass der knoblauch
bitter wird da halt nur bitter gewann
man mit der beta von der schwarzwild
nein wenn man ihnen im bitter lemon
einlegt und dann wieder bitter so jetzt
aber hier
den knoblauch gewürfelt genau hier haben
das fleisch ein bisschen noch anbraten
die temperatur kann wissen erhöhen also
auf 8 was man den erdnüssen die erdnüsse
gesalzen 75 gramm und gerüstet wenn man
auch noch rein
es gibt in ganz noch in so ein
spezielles aroma und jetzt hatten wir
auch noch kaufen
in der zwischenzeit ruhig ein bisschen
auch okay
bis gleich haben jetzt angebraten musik
sagt leicht anbraten dass es nicht zu
linke solltest du jetzt extra was wir
jetzt machen wir bleiben bei dieser
panne und thun grad hier alles rein was
ich klein gehackt haben zack und das tut
es richtig schön anbraten
wir haben wir das anbraten ich schon mal
die kavallerie ins nudelwasser und war
der silber gefächert ist überkocht
deswegen haben wir die kupplung mit
rauch und hier hat die nun einfach
verliebt und jetzt richtig scharf
anbraten
das riecht schon so richtig genial
lecker die ganzen ersten ist ja das
ganze die ganzen röster um die zwiebeln
knoblauch wahnsinn
[Musik]
okay die nun kochen jetzt noch
vielleicht noch fünf minuten wichtig bei
null ist nicht ganz ganz wichtig ist wir
müssen es sei richtig sie hat richtig
sie müssen ein bisschen zeit und wie
gesagt ja wir schon richtig tolle
röstaromen der zieht das riecht schon
richtig schön verbrannt ist es aber
nicht es ist nur gerüstet was ich jetzt
noch machen werde ist um den geschmack
noch ein bisschen mehr herauszukitzeln
habe ich hier noch eine richtig tolle
minute mir das natürlich schon
ja wahnsinn was macht kommt nein das
kann ich lernen
erfüllt man geboren habe das gesehen hat
es gesehen so ein bisschen kleiner und
etwas zu scharf mit den kernen zusammen
kein problem das verdaute körper das
brennt übrigens zweimal dreimal einmal
mund einmal im bauch und einmal morgen
früh so jetzt habe das gemacht jetzt zur
folge es noch das gleiche was ich vorher
rausgenommen habe das ist nicht trocken
wird habe ich jetzt wieder rein
wahnsinn so und jetzt schon mal schön
anbraten 1 2 minuten
hier sehen wir ganz gut kann nicht
überkochen und zwischenzeitlich räumen
auf was ich jetzt noch dazu gäbe ist
einfach kokosmilch wie das sie nicht
gezögert ist sondern eine ganz neutrale
sagen wir einen fehler gemacht die tiere
dürften nicht machen und zwar bevor die
chorus ist das schild wieder schütteln
so jetzt schöne zuerst nachdem sie
geschüttelt haben da stimmt was nicht
wo siehst du bist wirklich was ist
passiert nichts und zwar das ist
kokosmilch kokosmilch ist nämlich keine
milch sondern
das sei nicht geschmackvoll
geschmackvoll aus aber jetzt soll die
chorus ist mir ein rohr
ich habe mir vorher gesagt nun sogar ist
etwas dickflüssiger als die tomatensauce
und etwas flüssiger als ein pesto und
das wird jetzt auch jetzt so schön
vermengen
ich gehe von von von der stufe 6 auch
schon für drei runter und lass es jetzt
doch schön ein bisschen köcheln in dem
es immer mehrmals rum rühre woher weiß
ich woher weiß ich das sehr genau so
richtig lecker was jetzt noch fehlt ist
kerbe und zwar kerbel ist ein assist
sind kräuter und zwar ist es vom
geschmack her wie anis und das ist gut
für die nieren das ist gut für exzesse
und für was ist noch gut ähnlich exzesse
lohnexzesse sind was ganz anderes
genau für pickel so ganz einfach die
kleinkinder einfach verbiegen so
trainieren natürlich gut und er musste
immer ganz frisch und ganz zum schluss
drauf gemacht haben oder wenn ich
richtig schön nach anis können gar nicht
kann ja wisst ihr wo kerbel herkunft 9
und zwar kommt aus süd süd süd aus
russland so es kommt aus russland
100 prozent und es wächst immer märz
woher weiß ich es ja manchmal weiß ich
das wollte
in russland wird welches vorher auf
wikipedia gelesen habe
es riecht ganz ganz toll etwas süßlich
dies ist aber nicht weil ich warum das
ja warum sie sich süßlich weil ich ihn
reingemacht habe jetzt auch sechs lassen
es ganz kurz einmal aufkochen
in der zwischenzeit holen nehmen wir die
falle
vom herd sind wir noch gut ja diesen 100
prozent gut so
und zwar jetzt auch ein trick wie man
das macht sinn wenn man sich die finger
nicht verbrennt und zwar kann man
einfach das ding senkrecht nach oben
wahnsinniges jagd warum weil wir schon
mal die finger verbrannt haben so thomas
auf die seite und jetzt tun die nudel
einfach abkochen jetzt um die nudel
dritten topf richtig so das war ein
special effect habt ihr angst bekommen
ja habt ja weil ich angst bekommen
gerade eben jetzt nehme ganz einfach nur
zwei sachen machen entweder tun ist so
jetzt direkt hier in die pfanne in den
topf oder wir tun es einfach jetzt am
tisch servieren und tun ist so gut rüber
gießen was macht auch okay also wenn man
hier die suche und machen das richtig
schon drüber sieht das bild natürlich
richtig blöd aus aber dann kannst du mal
der eintopf in allen töpfen und ich mal
reingucken jetzt so ein bisschen rum
rühren und die jungs tun schon einen
tisch richten und dann machen wir was
richtig cooles mal coole bilder und dann
probleme auch mal wie schmeckt ist aber
ehrlich haben recht müssen alle richtig
sei aber okay
jetzt wo es auch schon geschossen jetzt
dass sie hat man sie ja mal probieren
mal sehen ob es schmeckt sehr ehrlich
sein doch dann sind das jemand auf
anfrage mit und sagte heute die opti nun
auch richtig schöne al dente sind also
diesmal das fleisch muss richtig saftig
sein
sei ehrlich jetzt wirklich also nudeln
da ist man also auf jeden fall ja einzig
ein bisschen fit ist alles aber
ansonsten kann das heißt wir sagen euch
was haben wir vergessen
ich wollte ja man wir haben seien
vergessen ja richtig verstehen wir
hatten salz vergessen wir haben gar kein
salz und pfeffer rein gemacht stimmt
stimmt richtig okay hier hast du salz
mehr salz nicht mehr groß wie normal
lass mal ausprobieren lassen wovon viele
leute angst haben das weiß ich ist er
von von der kokosmilch schmeckt mega
[Musik]
kokosmilch hat bisher noch dazu perfekt
ihr seid ja ein bisschen salz pfeffer
salz und sie habe ich halt nie gegessen
und schrecklich habe ich gerade gegessen
zu bunt ist und das ding auch schön
witzig also wir haben was gegessen
ich hab vergessen zu salzen und pfeffern
aber jetzt super jetzt mit dem sonst
verfügt wahnsinn ich glaub ich werd
immer immer immer besser
das ist wirklich der wahnsinn was ich in
den letzten monaten gelernt habe vom
kochen
das ist gar nicht so schwer und wie
schnell friert wollen würde und nur bei
schloss ich mache mein eigenes ding
ich glaube ich meinen eigenen kanal oder
was die frau kann ja auch oder ihr habt
mir ist auch super unter kerbel dar und
ist richtig ab und zwar ist es das
geheimnis der kerbel zusammen mit der
kokosnuss mit dem mit anis und mit der
kokosnuss kommt ein richtig cooler nicht
mag kann ich will ich bis jetzt noch
nicht wahnsinnig cool
wir machen das nach schmeckt richtig
lecker kochen auf geringem
bildungsniveau funktioniert hier setzt
audi q5 also tschüss macht gut
kommentiert schaut geht auf see ließ -
blog.de dann bekommt ihr schon mal
schriftlich ansonsten wie gesagt
abonniert diesen kanal ist ganz ganz
wichtig dann verpasste gar kein video
aktiviert die glocke und macht auf die
glocken muss markieren auf immer genau
dass man immer das videobild vielen dank
macht's gut
morath
[Musik]
einfach selbst zeit ist apfel zeit ich
möchte ein drei-gänge-menü zaubern und
in jedem gang tochter apfel auf in der
vorspeise in der hauptspeise in der
nachspeise und das soll alles so
unterschiedlich schmecken so dass keine
langeweile aufkommt fünf schafe über
herzhaften blätterteig bis hin zu süßen
tarte das apfel mini und fertig marcel
ii sonntag 16 uhr bei vox